buongiorno un po di tempo fa mi sono
pesato la mia bilancia ha chiesto
veramente piangendo di salire uno alla
volta e ho capito quindi che la
situazione abbastanza tragica così ho
postato su instagram un sondaggio del
quale chiedevo se provare la dieta
crudista fosse provare quella frutta
riana ha vinto la dieta crudista grazie
vado a fare la spesa che sa per la
maggior parte frutta carrube non so
nemmeno cosa sia una carrubba e vabbè ho
visto che presidente non si può mangiare
un chiedo scusa alle persone che magari
mi diranno se politi magari e basta
mangiare poco e che facessi una dieta
equilibrata
io equilibrio dove iniziamo speso
qualcosa tipo 50 euro
perché quella roba lì e pizza vostra
perché tutto questo loro se so fatti la
pizza mentre io sono entrato come
l'anguria sto mangiando mandorle dal
quarto d'ora e ho beccato quell'unica
man tornata in rovina poi sapori tutte
le altre mandorle e la banana impegnato
stasera su scivola sono tornato a casa e
mentre rosario
rosario pulisce l'angolo io muoio di
fame e credo che andrò a farmi
un'ennesima banana e perché è un frutto
mobilissime se non fosse la ventesima
immagine dello scherzo la seconda se
oggi sto andando avanti alla banana e
mandorle così perché mi odio sto
mangiando i finocchi
stamattina mi sono svegliato
relativamente tardi e dopo il sushi di
ieri non avevo tanta fame credo che
questo senso di sazietà veramente non
sia dovuto al fatto che questa dieta yo
lo stia facendo in maniera corretta
piuttosto è dovuto al fatto che ho
mangiato così tanto che se non è
veramente io ancora in circolo roba di
capodanno quindi la mia vera
preoccupazione è che oggi possa
incominciare a farsi sentire la fame ed
è il motivo per cui io visto che
comunque ogni sono un record riesco a
capire il futuro e in parte
ho deciso di farmi per pranzo una
ricetta buonissima avete presente quelle
cose che su internet dicono delizioso
queste mandorle stato proprio di
formaggio
ecco farò quella che vedremo come va
perché se non mi ingozzo perbene arrivo
stasera che le mere piuttosto a magna
armelin filo non so il corpo e
l'immaginazione ciò inutile inutile
illudendosi sempre stato inutile perché
noi cosa accendi però capito questo
oddio oddio santo scusatemi ragazzi per
questo spettacolo sono appena notato una
cosa che questa ricetta qua cosa che
dice taglio non riesco adagia contrario
tagliolini di zucca roberta italiani di
zucca piccolo letta male e ha posto la
zucca ho preso le zucchine
la cosa positiva è compreso oppure
questa cosa su amazon per cercare di
fare gli spaghetti dalle zucchine che
per me un pochino me fare lo so
le bistecche dagli infissi non solo che
si faccia
ok ragazzi ci sto riuscendo un po a
fatica modeo porno youtube porno youtube
guardate che carini proprio che la rotta
da l'aspetto non è orribile nel senso
mangiano cose più brutte di questa roba
il terrore nel sapore ma anche
assaggeremo adesso le bacchette perché
vanno più food blogger ma pazzo né
rocce buffa
la mia domanda è ci arrivo vivo tipo
allo spuntino è buonissimo buon inizio a
crepare di fame
sono uscito grazie a dio mi sono portato
una banana è ormai sto diventando un
primate perché mi sto mangiando talmente
banale non so quanto potassio possa
reggere un corpo prima che si trasformi
in veleno se qualcuno lo sa me lo faccia
sapere qua sotto il suo tornato a casa
non mi la mia mente di cucinare e quindi
ordinato di nuovo il sushi e di roma
angelo sashimi anche sto facendo pochino
di ironia su instagram è una cosa che ho
notato è che ho più energie
non so se è quel piccolo bus di energia
che si dice alcune persone abbiano prima
di apprestarsi alla morte anche perché
ieri a cena un peccato dei ragazzi
simpaticissimi e secondo me ho fatto
un'ottima impressione
aspettiamo il cibo che si svegliassero
non posso mangiare l'integra l'uno posso
mangiare l'integrale posso solamente
mangiare cruda perché integrale comunque
cotto capisci la follia
non capisco come mangino i carboidrati
loro terzo giorno continua pranzo a base
di sushi ma hanno spiegato che avrò
delle reazioni allergiche che non è una
cosa sana e desidero questo riso più di
quanto possa desiderare vengono sono
battute sconce quindi chiedo qualche
buona una cena offerta qui dalla mia
amica
no infatti ti metto ti mettono censura
perché sarebbe la rete un atto cattivo
kakà in questo momento sì come quelli
intervistati dalle iene che avranno la
voce modificata il recensore sulla
faccia quindi puoi dire quello che ti
pare
va benissimo per 8 posti trio brutto che
bello allora questa qui un'insalata di
mandarini di cui alcuni sono cosparsi di
liquame vogliamo far vedere ma comunque
mi sembrano m m's c'è una mela che stava
lì da quanto perché per un bella sede
mangiato da poco e poi rucola e
la via valeriana che non lo so per uno
che sta morendo di fame sono un pacco di
patatine aggiungiamo il sesamo sti
lamponi ammesso affanno in serata un
dolce perché non ho capito ma vanno bene
tutti questi giappone no non è una
crostata dai basta tutto questo io
mangio davanti a questo possiamo per un
attimo scusami il frigo cioè ragazzi io
devo resistere a tutta sta roba cui io
solitamente qui apro e della cuccagna e
invece oggi se piagne star luce così
questo è dietro sta iniziando a
risultare pesante mangio almeno sempre
le stesse cose in realtà molte cose
diverse non mi sembra sempre di mangiare
la stessa roba freschina cruda che
disprezza sullo stomaco e la rimane e
quindi incomincia a diventare un po
stressante ieri sera poi è successa una
cosa che non ho ripreso per rispetto
delle altre persone perché dopo la cena
che ho fatto a casa dei miei mi ci sono
uscito a cena fuori con altre persone
nel brutto riprendere tutti quanti e ho
preso un insalata un'altra vede tutto
tipo di insalata mentre lo si sono
sfondati ragazzi pizze e bruschette
fritti cose che io lunedì prossimo ci
vado di anche ieri che senso abbia fare
stregata se poi mi lancio lunedì a
mangiare messa non stop però sono stato
bravo
non ho toccato nulla iniziati entro e
pesante oggi salgono a milano
vado da lui non possono ancora un giallo
scimemi sera cioè si posso voi avete la
torta della nonna in frigo e i
bocconcini di pollo all'arancia per
nessuno mangia il certo i bocconcini di
pollo perché vedi tekemaya luca rota
vorrei nega le carote tipo le pillole
dimagranti
alla vista mangerò questa insalata di
funghi crudi con limone e compagnia
bella
questo bacile dei finocchi non ce la
faccio più sto mangiando solo finocchi
mi sembra restare al pride
la cosa veramente scomoda di questa
dieta è che ssd fretta come lo sono io
adesso devo fare 2000 appuntamenti e
compagnia bella
ai più fece fare una colazione al volo
non ti mandi a colazione latte estero
reali da biscotti ems o cotti
attraversano tutti quanti comunque dei
processi latte arma il latte per poter
essere parzialmente scremato intero
vedevo già fatto bollire perché bisogna
prendere ha detto non è malvagio ma è un
po difficile devi conoscere una dieta
così devi informarti cosa che scusami
non ho fatto il salmone crudo viene
cotto in congelatore venne abbattuto in
contrada non viene cotto sicuro ma cosa
stai dicendo
la cottura non avviene solo tramite
fuoco tramite un freddo anche i cibi
sull'uomo
vabbè io continuo questa roba
vediamo appunto che altro cioè per
andare a milano carè costante ci sono io
con la madonna dietro e la dice lunga su
come mi sento in questo momento
non lo so lo so bene cosa che ci nel
congelatore si cuociono fra sei rimasto
di tutto deve durare altri tre giorni
per il disastro
è bollente a dir poco ecco la dieta non
so grassi cosa cela dentro le arance
basta soffritto in farina sa bene
possibilità o la farina e gps
se chiudo gli occhi e tutto indietro
nella lingua sanno di pollo all'arancia
qualcosa di crudista viene qua non
volevo dirti un no poverino noto è preso
in giro scusami odio prendere in giro le
persone innocenti aggiornamenti del
crudismo sono qui è arrivato a milano
con lui che sta male e non solo regione
ticino poverino ho mangiato un po di
mele mentre stava in treno ma sento che
mi fa uno ma la pancia e 2 che io non mi
sento sazio
no io mi sento pieno pieno di plastica
tipo pieno di roba che non riesco a
buttare giù e a digerire mi sta un pò
antipatica sta dietro
magari non la so fare io ma queste facce
voglia di nuovo di mangiare qualcosa di
reale ma è la diversa scenico è stata di
avere il crudismo come fate che ricette
conoscete che non sto capendo è un
limite mio non mi sono forse documentato
avere un professionista mi seguisse
sempre salmone conto secondo me troppo
non so quanto vada bene ma il mercurio
con tutte quelle malate li guarda che
tra tonno e salmone sono i pesci
peggiori tra dico per esperienza intensa
verte sul serio dalle cose medietà della
palestra
il maggiore quota industriale tonno e
poi invece sono stato male al 4 giorni
me sto male racconta così non sarebbero
state di schino vado si patate crude con
il provola guanciale di suino nero è
così
il tutto e tutto crudo più forte delle
patatine con scamorza e bacon clou di
step sa che sembra un hamburger cotto
con bacon scamorza tipo non lo so pure
le mutande di mia nonna a me in realtà e
crudista ve lo giuro ve lo giuro anche
quelle crudista buongiorno è sempre
giorno anche se a casa il look riuscita
vecchia fanno sempre sembrare che tutti
si è svegliato alle 3 di notte per
andare a pisciare sto molto meglio con
la pancia dopo
diciamo questo break 6 molto meglio sono
contento lui
diciamo una dato la forza per ritornare
in carreggiata quindi adesso sto facendo
un pranzo a base di toast crew
distinguere quanto è credibile detto il
ds il kurdistan di che cosa abbiamo
invece quale costruzione dell'avvocato
pomodoro si fruga nel formaggio come
sembra
c'è il formaggio crudista sembra
formaggio filante sembra quasi cotto è
vero è pazzesco abbiamo trovato questo
guarda l'uovo finto pazzesco procede la
cena qui abbiamo però tutta quanta roba
crudista perché comunque abbiamo a lillo
prezzemolo pomodoro
del sale e non ho mai mangiato con la
roba tartufo e poi loro delle vongole
crudisti cioè che per il momento stanno
lì non sono cotte e non si stanno man
coprendo quindi adesso dovrò utilizzare
altri noti personaggi voi si muove il
signor limonetto che sta ricco e guardia
niente bene allora ok per questa basta
della rivista bisogno
quanto a mettere gli spaghetti
a macerare in acqua frizzante invece
vede vedere che fa tutte le bollicine
l'acqua e poi invece a parte mettete a
macerare le vongole con il pomodoro nel
olio e aglio e teoricamente dovrebbe
venir vi vedete fuori una una crema così
le vongole lasceranno questo liquido e
dover penso insomma venire una roba
crudista
cosa casinò no quelli sono dei letti ma
sono dei led che ho messo apposta è lui
l'uomo bravissimo che a raccolta
una bottiglia potete anche usare quelle
del vino se se volete romano esatto se
ce l'avete tu che bravo essere stato a
metterci il tappo di nuovo bravo
per questo il risultato della diciamo
degli spaghetti con le vongole cronisti
come un po salati è un tantino ho
cercato di portare immaginato troppo 2
esatto esatto il sale diciamo che volevo
portare il mare a tavola allora ragazzi
quell'ora non si sia capito la dieta
crudista è il male
per quanto mi riguarda sono sicuro di
aver sbagliato 200.000 cose ma allo
stesso tempo credo e magari chi è
crudista melo potrà scrivere qui e potrà
dirmi e potrà contraddirmi ma credo che
per il mio stomaco dopo un po mangiare
crudo sia veramente un inferno vi dico
solo che avevo una pancia piena d'aria
mamma che sembravo incinta e l'unico
modo che avevo per togliere la panzana
partorire tutta quell aria e non era
bello per me è perché mi stava attorno
detto ciò vi saluto credo di avere di
aver condiviso con voi un pò troppo
informazioni tirando un bacio al
prossimo video ciao ragazzi
no non era più buono sta videocamera che
quello comandato fino ad oggi